buenos días
y se han preguntado ustedes o les han
dicho lo importante que es poner las
cosas en su lugar la verdad es que
cuando yo hago eso cuando yo me escucho
diciendo eso recuerdo cuando cuando era
chico unos 89 años y mi mamá me busca me
mandaba a buscar algo y las situaciones
que me podía tardar las horas buscando
eso y no encontrarlo y bueno por
supuesto mi mamá enojada me decía qué
estás haciendo estás loco ya lleva dos
horas ahí buscándolo y no encuentras
nada
y eso es parte de dejar las cosas en su
lugar nosotros sabemos que buscar
nosotros sabemos dónde está y no
consumimos tiempo y no generamos una
sensación negativa si me permiten
ejemplificar lo de una manera diferente
me gustaría mostrarles una imagen donde
pongo un producto
si yo les pidiera a ustedes de
emergencia en un whatsapp oye amigo
amiga por favor cómprame este este
producto lo encuentras en la tienda x y
z ahí ahí están sin problema alguno y
bueno sin más hace el favor y vas a esta
tienda seguramente vas a ir a un punto
en específico la situación es que cuando
nosotros vemos un objeto creamos un
modelo mental y este modelo mental nos
ayuda a reconocerlo y al reconocerlo
bueno pues nos dice dónde buscarlo la
mayoría de las veces que he pedido que
me digan dónde busquen este producto la
mayoría de las veces me dice en el
departamento de vinos y licores
suponiendo que van ustedes ahí el
departamento de vinos y licores me han
dicho
yo no lo conozco que es grande que hay
muchos productos y las situaciones que
tendrías que estar buscando en los
estantes en los pasillos este producto
les digo no lo van a encontrar allí y si
ustedes son muy muy muy mis amigos se
irán a otro departamento a buscarlo tal
vez dónde están los refrescos tal vez
donde estén los jugos y tampoco lo van a
encontrar ahí sale el resultado es que
pierdes tiempo no lo encuentras generas
una emoción negativa y finalmente podría
salir de la tienda sin comprar el
producto
y esto se vuelve realmente una historia
triste porque alguien se encargó de
producir eso y lo que quiere es que se
venda y si no se vende no es tanto
porque el producto sea malo simple y
sencillamente porque las personas no lo
encuentran
bueno
qué es lo que me ayuda a mí a organizar
los productos en el mundo digital lo que
me ayuda es algo que se conoce como
arquitectura de información la
información en este sentido la podemos
ver nosotros como un producto lo tenemos
que colocar por ejemplo en una página
web y en ese sentido
normalmente se acostumbra a estructurar
la la página hay diferentes formas de
estructurar lo presentó en primer plano
una de las más recurridas donde tenemos
cinco espacios arriba abajo al centro de
la izquierda a la derecha y se colocan
elementos que nada más van en ese
espacio en específico
el área de estudio que me ayuda a mí a
organizar y estructurar la información
es algo que se conoce como la
arquitectura de la información y su
definición es muy sencilla es el arte y
la ciencia de darle forma a los
productos y experiencias relacionados
con la información para apoyar la
usabilidad la capacidad de búsqueda y la
comprensión
básicamente la arquitectura de
información conecta personas con
contenido y así en el mundo digital las
personas no se pierden no consumen mucho
tiempo buscando las cosas
no se desesperan y si es el caso pueden
comprar o adquirir algún producto
todo es muy sencillo la definición
realmente es muy muy sencilla no
obstante me generó una idea perdón una
pregunta la pregunta es por qué
relaciono el arte
en esta definición que utilizo
fuertemente en el mundo de las
computadoras el arte en esta definición
no me hacía clic y yo busqué en libros y
busqué en revistas las respuestas y
francamente si bien encontraba un
poquito de información no quedaba
plenamente satisfecho la respuesta a la
fue encontrando nada más y nada menos
que en el museo de guadalupe
dejen les cuento una pequeña historia de
este de este recinto en 1707 no era
museo pero ya existía era el colegio de
propaganda fide de nuestra señora de
guadalupe básicamente era un centro de
evangelización y educación en la
religión católica
entonces lo primero que yo reflexioné es
que alguna pintura que encontraba en
este museo posiblemente era considerado
en aquellos tiempos como un recurso
didáctico y como docente cuando nosotros
elaboramos un recurso didáctico debemos
estar seguros que lo que queremos
transmitir sea lo más directo y que se
entienda y que lo pueda recordar el
alumno entonces yo tenía que ver las
imágenes que encontraba en este museo de
manera diferente y encontrar la
respuesta porque está relacionado el
arte con la arquitectura y la
información no fue una búsqueda sencilla
no fue en una visita y ya encontró la la
respuesta fui en diferentes ocasiones
durante diferentes años incluso
lo pidieron que empecé a encontrar fue
patrones
me fui por un patrón muy sencillo yo no
soy experto en el arte pero sí pude
encontrar salas por ejemplo en la sala
de las santas y los doctores de
parte de lo que se muestra en el museo
las imágenes son muy sencillas tiene un
fondo sobrio y sobre ese fondo está un
personaje en este caso vemos a santa
catarina
perdón a santa
catalina perdón allá por el rumbo en el
punto de eso
que el elemento era
no tenía más más elementos que poner
solamente la santa y en ese sentido
bueno encontré que el espacio central es
donde va la información más importante
entonces buscando o tratando de hacer un
clic entre la estructura de una página
web que en principio para mí no tiene
que ver nada que ver con una obra pues
encontré que el espacio central
realmente se utiliza como poner lo más
importante luego revise otras otras
obras y encontré dos espacios que están
perfectamente definidos uno era el que
estaba arriba y abajo arriba colocábamos
o colocaban perdón elementos divinos
como el espíritu santo
abajo colocaban elementos terrenales o
del lado oscuro de la fuerza y en este
sentido bueno pues me quedó claro que
hay cosas que ponemos arriba en la obra
en medio y abajo hay veces que nuestro
lenguaje es tan rico que
lo hacemos un lado y utilizamos palabras
que
que pierden fuerza dejarlo en arriba y
abajo la verdad es que le resta
importancia qué tal si decimos en la
parte superior y el simple hecho de
decir superior estamos estableciendo que
es algo extraordinario y en la parte
inferior y ahí estamos estableciendo que
es algo menor que no tiene tanta
importancia entonces ahí ya empecé a ver
una estructura y me animé más a hacerlo
un análisis en otras obras aquí en la
siguiente obra muestro a san josé y a un
lado tiene al papa pio sexto y al otro
lado al rey de españa carlos tercero uno
representando al poder de la iglesia del
otro lado se representa el poder civil
cuál de los dos poderes era el más
fuerte y en ese sentido yo podía
encontrar qué porción de la imagen es
más importante entre ambas
la respuesta la encontré ligando con lo
que yo ya había aprendido en la en la
en la imagen pasada de establecer un
punto superior aquí lo único que hice
fue una prueba muy sencilla atrás de una
línea horizontal y me di cuenta que el
papá estaba sutilmente colocado un poco
más arriba que el rey carlos tercero en
este sentido me daba cierta evidencia de
que el espacio donde va colocado el papá
es más importante pero posiblemente
hubiera sido algo circunstancial porque
posiblemente el papá era una persona
robusta y el rey era una persona delgada
bajit entonces tenía que validar esta
esta situación y algo que aprendí en
visitando los museos fue que una cosa es
la perspectiva que por ejemplo tienen
ustedes al ver una obra y otra muy
distinta hacernos parte de la obra y
establecer otro punto de vista ahí la
izquierda y la derecha
también dicho de otra forma desde el
punto de vista de san jose a su derecha
está el papá ya su izquierda está el rey
la situación es que eso ya me dio
evidencia para establecer que la
posición donde está el papá es más
importante y la evidencia estaba
nuevamente en él en ese uso del lenguaje
en aquellos tiempos no decían derecha e
izquierda
decían diestra y siniestra y en ese
sentido si yo les pidiera vamos a hacer
dos equipos las personas o grupo de
personas que quieren estar a la diestra
vénganse para acá y con la siniestra
pues véngase para acá yo estoy más que
seguro que la mayoría de nosotros nos
irá con la diestra porque la siniestra
tiene una connotación no tan positiva
estamos entonces yo aquí ya empecé a
a pensar que definitivamente la
arquitectura de información y el arte
estaban ligadas pero me faltaba
establecer un punto y el punto era el
impacto que había tenido este tipo de
estructuras en aquellos tiempos y
caminando por el museo todavía el museo
me dio la capacidad de encontrar la
respuesta
recordando un poquito de historia
nosotros nos damos cuenta que al norte
de la nueva españa se encuentran
ciudades establecidas por las misiones
franciscanas básicamente lo que quiero
decir es que hay ciudades que se
fundaron con el nombre de los angeles
san francisco san josé san diego santa
fe- san antonio y son ciudades que ya
tienen años de haberse fundado y no
tengo ningún dato de algún presidente
que haya querido quitarles el nombre ya
tienen sólidamente un sustento ya son
parte de la comunidad y realmente no no
tiene mucho sentido cambiarles el nombre
a estas ciudades esta es la última
prueba que yo necesitaba para establecer
que el arte realmente contribuye en algo
que yo pensaba que era del mundo única y
exclusivamente de las computadoras
en este punto pues alguien me podría
decir oye juan pero realmente esas
ciudades
el nombre lo colocaron los
conquistadores españoles y yo tendría
que decir sí sí es cierto incluso
podríamos investigar un poquito más y
determinar que hubo exploradores
españoles que también hicieron su labor
pero los franciscanos también hicieron
su labor y en ese sentido pues la
reflexión que me dejó es que una cosa es
conquistar regiones y otra cosa
conquistar mentes y corazones cuando
llegó a ese punto yo ya llegó
prácticamente convencido incluso sufrió
una transformación dentro del museo y me
doy cuenta que parte de este viaje que
le llamamos vida pues realmente sé
se condimenta cuando nosotros tenemos la
capacidad de hacernos preguntas cuando
tenemos nosotros la capacidad de buscar
e indagar más allá de lo que está
superficial y en este sentido pues yo
los invito a que se hagan preguntas y se
diviertan en este viaje que llamamos
vida
y bueno para contribuir en esa en esta
situación de preguntas seguramente usted
es bueno y esto esperaría que se estén
preguntando bueno y la botella donde
ésta sale
y si no están preguntando eso bueno pues
tampoco no pasa nada sale
pero es muy interesante darte cuenta
dónde o cómo clasifican las cosas las
personas y cómo es que nos dificultan a
nosotros encontrarlas entonces nuestra
labor es hacerlo más sencillo la
respuesta es muy sencilla
mi esposa me hubiera dicho la botella la
encuentras a un lado de los cereales
obvio sale
realmente no no es obvio pero ahí está
ahí lo podemos encontrar y esta
situación es una dificultad que tenemos
que analizar no solamente en el mundo
digital también en nuestra vida
cotidiana para colocar las cosas en su
lugar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]